bindi Irwin pack John the QPD a with  boyfriend Chandler Powell at Disney  World recently there is someone special  in my life right now the pair was  snapped at the happiest place on earth  holding hands and laughing as they  navigated their way through the park  your family life he's wanted to play the  minions 17 year old Dancing with the  Stars champ kept it casual rocking Turin  jean shorts a tee and a hoodie Mindy was  vocal about how supportive her man was  while she was competing on the hit ABC  show and we love that they're still  going strong Chandler here as well it's  really funny because every night I'll  come home it'll be like okay let's get  the ice let's get a cup of tea and let's  get you food I think that that love and  support is just is something that we all  will need in life